we now come to the third and final kind
of calculation out of the calculations
that we carried out in our earlier
example the setting is exactly the same
as in our discussion of the total
probability theorem we have a sample
space which is partitioned into a number
of disjoint subsets or events which we
think of as scenarios we are given the
probability of each scenario and we
think of these probabilities as being
some kind of initial beliefs they
capture how likely we believe each
scenario to be now under each scenario
we also have the probability that an
event of interest event B will occur
then the probabilistic experiment is
carried out and perhaps we observe that
event B did indeed occur once that
happens maybe this should cause us to
revise our beliefs about the likelihood
of the different scenarios having
observed that B occurred perhaps certain
scenarios are more likely than others
how do we revise our beliefs by
calculating conditional probabilities
and how do we calculate conditional
probabilities we start from the
definition of conditional probabilities
the probability of one event given
another is the probability that both
events occur divided by the probability
of the conditioning event how do we
continue well we simply realize that the
numerator is what we can calculate using
the multiplication rule and the
denominator is exactly what we calculate
using the total probability theorem so
we have everything we need to calculate
those revised beliefs or conditional
probabilities and this is all the reason
the Bayes rule it is actually a very
simple calculation it's a very simple
calculation however it is a quite
important one
it's history goes way back in the middle
of the 18th century a Presbyterian
minister Thomas Bayes worked it out it
was published a few years after his
death and it was quickly recognized for
its significance it's a systematic way
for incorporating new evidence it's a
systematic way for learning from
experience and it forms the foundation
of a major branch of mathematics so
called Bayesian inference which we will
study in some detail later in this
course the general idea is that we start
with a probabilistic model which
involves a number of possible scenarios
and we have some initial beliefs on the
likelihood of each possible scenario
there's also some particular event that
may occur under each scenario and we
know how likely it is to occur under
each scenario this is our model of the
situation under each particular
situation the model tells us how likely
event B is to occur if we actually
observe that B occurred then we use that
information to draw conclusions about
the possible causes of B or conclusions
about the more likely or less likely
scenarios that may have caused this
event to occur and that's what inference
is having observed B we make inferences
as to how likely a particular scenario
AI is going to be and that likelihood is
captured by these conditional
probabilities of AI given the event B so
that's what the Bayes rule is doing
starting from conditional probabilities
going in one direction it allows us to
calculate conditional probabilities
going in the opposite direction it
allows us to revise the probabilities of
the different scenarios taking to
account the new information and that's
exactly what inference is all about as
we're going to see later in this
less